chizik west london one of the uk's most
desirable areas
the economy may have nosedived during
the pandemic but the housing market's
booming
with the number of sales at their
highest since records began
on the market there's three and a half
million dollar home
remote working normalized during the
pandemic means the sellers no longer
need to be in the capital for work
and many buyers are looking for more
space especially outside
so 180 000 transactions is what the
government data
is anticipating for march 2021
and that's the highest level on record
since the
um since they've recorded the data from
2005
so it's it's it's miles above what we
what we typically see
the average across the last 16 years has
been 82 000 transactions a month
the housing market is so important to
the nation's economy that the british
government simply
couldn't let it fail which is why it
introduced a property tax holiday
allowing buyers to save thousands of
dollars on purchases
buyers were also allowed to take 95
percent mortgages from banks
and lending agencies the problem is in
cities such as london
there simply aren't enough houses with
the kind of space
especially gardens that people now want
and we've seen house prices go up
steadily by several
thousand dollars every month
according to recent findings most people
in the uk think owning a home is more
important than getting married
or early retirement but the country's no
exception
house prices have risen in many big
western cities
fueled by a mix of low interest rates
land shortages
and construction that cannot keep up
with demand
but when the british government's
coveted 19 support schemes such as the
property tax holiday come to an end in
the next few months
the bubble warn economists will burst
house prices now are higher than
they've ever been before in england it's
not a stable
position that we're now in particularly
given that the
holiday from stamp duty is time limited
people know when it's going to stop
so when it stops that may trigger a
quite a significant
reaction particularly if the economy
suffers as well
the overheated markets also push prices
well beyond the reach of many
especially first-time buyers for the
past 20 years
prices have outpaced the rise in average
earnings despite the current surge in
sales there just simply aren't enough
affordable houses available
for many buyers owning a home has rarely
felt quite so
insecure neave barker al jazeera
london